of course you're gonna have headlines
and fans wondering are you guys breaking
up are you parting ways
were you surprised at that reaction well
not
really some things that aren't even true
get spread and they catch fire and then
their headlines and click baits so
but to be honest we weren't worried
about that i feel like me and tyler
have been on the same page for a long
time and we've been very clear with our
fans we put a video out back in january
we created some freedom for ourselves to
do some solo stuff to do some collabs to
focus on
really whatever we want to do and and
that's an amazing place to be so i feel
like we've been clear with our fans
we kind of outlined what was going to go
on we're staying together we're going to
tour
nothing's changing oh that's awesome to
hear
[Music]
did you ever have moments of kind of
being like okay right i'm doing this on
my own here like
all the pressure is essentially on your
own shoulders was there fear just
pure excitement getting into this enough
fear to drive me to go forward i like
i like in that moment because i don't
want to be complacent i don't want to
just be comfortable i always want to be
chasing
something or working on a project or
challenging myself you know i think
that's important
good times good vibes good
[Music]
i honestly feel like my cup is
overflowing just super grateful our fans
continue to support us and all of our
adventures adventures and just all our
crazy ideas and it's just a blessed life
we get to live i couldn't be happier